monsieur le ministre les enseignants
lettres classiques qui ne sont pas les
seuls concernés alertent aujourd'hui sur
le recrutement de leur père a priori le
concours 2023 risque d'être bis répétita
problématique au vu du nombre
d'admissibles le nombre de professeurs
de lettres classiques recrutés infinés
pourraient retrouver le niveau de 2022
soit 55 postes pourvu sur les 134
proposés au concours du CAPES les
résultats d'admissibilité aux capacités
externes 2023 sont implacables seuls 47
candidats sont admissibles pour 134
postes à contrario en 2010 c'était
encore 242 candidats pour 170 postes en
2022 au comptait seulement 160 candidats
au CAPES 425 à l'agrégation ce déficit
alarmant au tempora mettant danger
l'enseignement du latin et du grec en
France en 2022 on comptait 14,6% de
collégiens 3% de lycées en latinistes
0,8,8% de collégiens 0,7% de lycéens et
les listes selon Le Figaro étudiant il
pourtant des facto des vocations je peux
en témoigner l'enseignement de ces
humanités d'une grande richesse adwitter
metternam rigueur manipulation des
langues histoire réflexion sur le
devenir des civilisations et de
l'humanité accéder à ses enseignements
exigeants et pour certains élèves en
vecteur puissant de réussite et ce à
fortiori lorsqu'on a pas toutes les
chances au départ les professeurs de les
classiques s'inquiète aussi sauf à taux
des difficultés consécutives mutations
difficiles voire impossible du fait de
l'absence d'options langue et culture
l'Antiquité remplacement ardu la
complémentarité des lettres classiques
et des Lettres Modernes au sein de
l'éducation nationale est une condition
sinequanone dont les langues latines
grecques et français sont entremêlés
aussi Monsieur le Ministre quels sont
les mesures envisagées afin de
promouvoir les lettres classiques auprès
des jeunes garantir un nombre de postes
au summum pour cette merveilleuse
discipline plus généralement la question
du recrutement reste cruciale et je
profite d'un aparté je suis aussi
préoccupé que mes collègues garrot et
Favennec sur la question des urgences en
Mayenne
merci